people are very wrapped up in this
themselves you know
a man wrapped up in himself makes a very
small package indeed and
one of the issues i suspect is that uh
people are thinking of themselves a lot
you know if you want to
break out of that if you want to kind of
re-engage with society and have a better
chance
at a flourishing life it's not that you
need to think
less of yourself it is that you need to
think of yourself
less where no one's asking you to think
less of yourself but there
we are now told that uh we are not
allowed to tell the man who thinks he's
a woman that he's really a man because
gosh you know that's
it would be so awful for him it would be
so he he
just has this problem and so we all need
to go along with that
we're not allowed to say that it's
better to be married than
not to be married you know and going
back to our example at the bar you know
hitting the bar every night and picking
up the cute check well some people just
can't get married right that
that's too bad yeah people suffer
everybody suffers okay
you and i have suffered everybody
watching this right now has suffered
and the the fact of that is is not
a reason to deny that there is such a
such a thing as the good or the true
or the beautiful the fact that we don't
always get to attain it
the fact that not every kid gets a
perfect sat score is not an argument for
doing away with the sats right it's an
argument for hopefully people can work a
little harder and we need to be nicer to
people
maybe who can't you know succeed in a
certain way and we've got to bring them
in and help them flourish and they're
like yeah
sure i'm all for that but don't don't
destroy the conception of excellence
don't destroy
the understanding of good and true and
beautiful and this is
this is something conservatives have
really fallen for because
what when the left comes in and destroys
the old standards they'll say look
what you think is good i think is bad
what you think is true i think is false
what you think is beautiful i think is
ugly
and the the modern conservative response
to that is like well i guess you're
right man
you know i guess yeah no accounting for
taste
but that's pretty lame and gives away
the whole game to the left the true
response has to be you're wrong you're
right
we're right and you're wrong and by the
way if if you're right and we're wrong
you need to convince me of that
you need to make an argument that
persuades me but the radical
subjectivism
that we have all fallen into is what has
allowed these kooky theories to take
hold i mean
you uh referenced this point i made in
the book uh earlier on
which is that the revolutions need to
take control of the common sense
this is the insight that began
political correctness it began about 100
years ago
you know marx failed to instigate his
worldwide revolution
he wanted all the the lower classes
right the working class to unite across
the world
they were going to throw off their
shackles and the chains of industry and
didn't happen turns out that the working
class
has feels much less of a bond to
its fellow proletariat proletarians than
it does
to its fellow countrymen its fellow
parishioners its fellow
members of their race its phil whatever
the whatever the the group is going to
be
and so antonio gramsci this brilliant
marxist theorist and communist
politician
he said ah the problem is the
conservatives have the common sense
they have the culture and so what we
need to do if we want the revolution to
succeed
we need to go in infiltrate all of these
institutions through a war of position
and then transform the common sense such
that
you know the workers who won't get on
board with our theories right now in the
factory
they will uh be so steeped in our
cultural and our ideology that they will
naturally
follow us and you know it's hard to deny
that the left has been fairly successful
at that over the last hundred years
my favorite quote that summarizes that
is the left won the culture war now
they're just driving around shooting the
survivors
which is just the most accurate thing it
really does seem to me like the left
really hate the working class at the
moment though do you get this sense
yeah there's a there is a clear disdain
and contempt
i mean you see this over the past year
with the
exaltation of our or dr fauci peace be
upon him and all the other
high priests of progressivism i mean
these are the the experts who know much
better
than the deplorable irredeemable
bitter clinging i mean these are the
words that just the democratic
presidential candidates and presidents
have used
to describe the lower classes also known
as
the american people a huge huge portion
of the american people
over the past 10 years they they hold
them in great contempt
and it's i think comes from an irony
that
the left purports to love humanity and
fight on behalf of humanity
and they're so focused on humanity they
they can't concern themselves with
actual humans the humans really drive
them nuts but humanity they love
it's weird as well because the vast
majority of
immigrant populations of black and
ethnic minorities
in america are probably going to be
working class
but it seems like their label of ethnic
minority
has superseded their label of working
class so the culture provides them
an exit route out and kind of a safe
space within the leftist ideology is
that right
yes and that this was gramsci's
observation too he said p people
actually don't
really identify with their job or their
their economic status
not anymore anymore yeah i mean but but
they
they they could identify much more with
say their religion their nationality
their race their
whatever um and and so that that does
give the left and out that's why the
the left has done very very well
certainly with uh with black voters but
with other minorities too other
immigrant groups
uh is because they can really gin up
that kind of uh
grievance and and resentment and where
it didn't exist before they'll they'll
sort of manufacture it
like they did through institutions like
the ford foundation and other
other groups in the 1970s um you know
even
the the moniker hispanic did not really
exist
you know before about 50 years ago the
idea that someone in mexico and brazil
and peru and guatemala and spain are all
somehow the same thing
is quite offensive i think actually but
same thing with asian the idea that
chinese japanese vietnamese indonesian
all that somehow it's all just the same
uh is uh offensive and silly but
politically it's very useful
and uh so you know they've they've
unfortunately
the left seems to understand politics
quite a bit better than we do and and
it's
a point i make in the book i think we as
conservatives tend to
pat ourselves on the back and we say we
understand reality so much but we
understand
speech free speech oh we're way smarter
about that than the left is
but the fact is we're not they they
understand it much better they
understand it's a role in an apology
much better
and it's how they've been able to
manipulate it so successfully while we
twiddle our thumbs
i definitely think they understand the
delivery mechanisms better
now everything that the left creates is
slicker
and sexier and cooler and i know you
guys at the daily wire are trying to
slowly sort of claw your way back into
the culture at the moment but it really
does feel like the left one the culture
war and now there's just
a few silos left over from the right
that are trying to sort of hold on
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that then press here
for the full unedited episode and don't
forget to subscribe
makes me very happy indeed peace